(light music)
- [Narrator] This is
Kamaria, a milky eagle owl.
The largest African owl,
it is found throughout sub-Saharan Africa.
The eagle in their name
refers to their large size.
Females are much larger than males,
sometimes over a third bigger.
They feed on a large variety of animals
everything from mammals, fish,
rodents and even large birds.
They hunt from a perch
using their sharp vision
to spot prey before flying in
and seizing them with
their powerful talons.
While it is a dominant bird,
its population has seen a decline
due to a combination of
loss of suitable habitat,
hunting, disease and drought.
Their slow reproductive rate
has made it difficult for the
population to recover quickly.
This is the milky eagle owl.
(light music)